here now with reaction Fox News
contributors Joe kcha kellyanne Conway
and the host of out kicks Tommy lren is
fearless Tommy lren kellyanne start with
you the polls speak volumes but here's
the strategy it's emerging it's very
simple they're going to talk about Maga
Republicans Trump Trump trump they're
going to talk about January 6 they're
going to demagogue abortion and then
they're going to use the old Playbook
Republicans are racist sexist homophobic
xenophobic islamophobic transphobic and
they want dirty air and water will
work it should not work if we let it
work we are the stupid party as new gri
sometimes likes to say I don't think
it'll work because I have faith in the
American people Sean this is a choice
between what you see with your own two
eyes and what they tell you you should
see with your own two eyes we see the
rising crime the rising prices we know
what's going on in the Middle East we
see every single day because of Fox News
and people like Bill maluan and Sarah
Carter and you showing us what's going
on at the border people know what they
see and they're going to vote according
to that now Joe Biden has nothing else
big people talk about Big Ideas and big
policy issues small people talk about
other people he has nothing else his
poll numbers are not just down in
disapproval generally but on every major
issue that America says is important to
them Joe Biden has made history as being
the oldest least inspiring least
accomplished and Le least ready to lead
president we've had in the wild if
Michelle Obama has a problem with all
this then she should have a talk with
Joe Biden and ding- dingding somebody we
rarely hear from kamla Harris she's made
history too not why you think she's made
history because her approval rating is
the lowest of any vice president since
we've been looking at it um one last
thing Sean on all of this well I want to
ask you this as a poster please yeah no
as a pollster I'm just wondering because
you've done this for years and you see
that he's losing huge numbers
demographically Hispanic Americans
African-Americans young people uh uh
women that are female voters like how
real are these numbers because he's
losing in some cases 20 25% of support
that is the base of the democratic
party the numbers are real Sean and the
excuse the Democrats use to keep Joe
Biden and KLA Harris on the ticket is
Trump Trump trump I challenge everyone
out there if you want to have a
conversation with someone who is
supporting Biden ask them a question
about Biden and see how many words or
seconds it takes them to say Trump they
can't get to 10 seconds or 10 words
without Trump Trump trump they simply
cannot Define him now what you just said
is important I think that we're going to
have a record number turn record number
voters among Hispanics why is that
relevant because one in every four
school children in this country is
Hispanic Hispanics on average are 30
years old is the average age of
Hispanics whites average age 44 Asians
and African-Americans about 35 37 this
is important because if you can lock up
the Hispanic vote if you can improve at
5 7 12% you basically win the election I
think Trump will do better among
Independents among firsttime voters
he'll do much better among uh certain
groups of women than people predict
because they are so sick and tired of
being talked to from the waist down only
you know what's a waist up for me my
eyes my ears my heart my mouth and my
brain and whichever party and its
candidates are willing to talk to women
from the waist up also can Prevail
January 6 2017 they talked about golden
showers and Russia collusion they
briefed the president-elect at Trump
Tower January 6 2021 is all Joe Biden
can focus on I can't believe this man
goes to Hallowed Ground like Liberty
like the Liberty belt in Independence
Hall in Pennsylvania like the am Church
where nine innocent people were
slaughtered and castigates and
denigrates and divides us people aren't
going to buite they want to be lifted up
not brought down by their presidents let
me go to Tommy Tommy the old Playbook
Maga Republicans democ ocracy in Peril
January 6th um you know is any of this
going to work Nazi analogies do you see
that working is that resonating you're
in touch with young people more than the
three of us no offense to my fellow
panelists but you know are young people
inspired by that does that mean anything
to
them I don't think they're inspired by
it but unfortunately it did work in 2020
we know Joe Biden really launched his
campaign with video images from
Charlottesville so this Playbook has
worked for them before but the Biden
campaign is operating as if Trump is the
nominee and he very well could be the
Republicans can't fall into the Trap
though of operating like Joe Biden is
going to be the nominee because as you
know Sean I don't think he's going to be
I think come the convention we're going
to have a major shakeup so if
Republicans are smart we will operate
and campaign as if we are campaigning
against any Democrat whether that be
Gavin Nome or Michelle Obama That's how
Republicans need to play this game
because simply focusing on frail Joe and
lost Joe and horrible economy Joe that's
going to work to decimate Joe's poll
numbers but if Joe is not the nominee we
better have a backup plan and we better
educate the American people on why the
Republican choice if that's Donald Trump
is the better choice remind them what
life was like under Donald Trump and how
good things were remind the young people
who maybe were quite young during that
time how great things were and that they
could maybe afford to buy a house or pay
their rent or pay for gas back when
Donald Trump was their president so that
has to be the move I would also say this
pay very close attention to how the
Obamas operate here because they don't
want their legacy tied to a failing Joe
Biden so if it looks like Joe Biden is
is really falling and tumbling even more
so than he is now I think they're going
to jump ship so watch them watch their
moves they're really in charge here all
right so let me go to Joe K because Joe
you you analyze the media better than
anybody you should have your own media
show it' be great um but there was
apparently an invitation only meeting
briefing in Delaware with the the media
the biggest contributors to Joe's
campaign in 2020 they allowed him to
hide in the basement they never fact
checked him uh they're not going to fact
check his failed record the only thing I
would add to what Tommy said and I think
she's right on the Mark is now the
difference between 2024 and 2020 is Joe
has a record and his record is atrocious
so in this briefing I'm assuming that
the mob in the media your friends you
know the blue check mark you know media
cult uh basically are getting their
talking points and and basically being
spoonfed what the Biden campaign is
going to want them to
say the old Sports analogy Sean is yes
they're they're working the refs and the
refs are more than willing to be worked
here as stenographers and this is a case
of a broken record being played to avoid
talking about an actual record to
kellyanne's point earlier because if
this is This president's grand opening
argument to kick off his campaign in
2024 by saying that he and he alone can
save democracy
then Joe Biden is in serious serious
trouble when it comes to re-election for
starters this is a president who spent
138 days last year in relaxing locations
and Posh vacation spots that was in 2023
so apparently saving democracy will be
done on a you know part-time basis chalk
full of long weekends at Bernie and and
we're seeing an obvious common thread in
these speeches from Biden lately in
terms of what we're not hearing about no
mention of the wonders of biomics no
mention of Americans drowning in credit
card debt no mention of the crisis that
is a catastrophe at the US Southern
border that even Democrats more and more
are sounding the alarm about no mention
about us test scores at their lowest in
decades no mention of the US looking
like a complete and utter laughing stock
to our adversaries because the
commander-in-chief apparently has no
idea where his defense secretary is
issues and Common Sense will win this
election and if Joe Biden thinks he
could run by ignoring his own record and
strictly demonizing Donald Trump who has
the issues on his side he will go down
as the first one-term Democratic
president since Jimmy Carter show here's
the problem with the January 6 fine if
you want to criticize Trump and that's
part of your argument that's fair um and
you could say he should have done a b or
c that's fair too here's the problem
they've never wanted to get to the whole
story the worst thing about the January
6 committee is they never put together a
plan to prevent something like that for
ever happening again the other thing Joe
is they never talked about the riots
they never spoke out about those rots in
the summer of 2020 and there were 574 of
them uh so I don't think it's writing
that they really cared about but they
never talked about even NBC and Lester
Holt Lester Holt reported there was
actionable Intelligence in the days
leading up to January 6th that never
came up in Liz Cheney's hearings uh or
the fact that the police chief the
Capitol Police Chief uh Sun who I've
interviewed who wrote a book about it he
saw the intelligence he was begging for
for National Guard help then I have the
acting defense secretary Miller his
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows president
Trump the days leading up to January 6
they never tell the story that Donald
Trump talked about bringing up the guard
and they'll never mention that he said
many of you will peacefully and
patriotically March to the capital so
your voices will be heard so it's an
incomplete picture but they acted and
the media went completely along with the
the the total narrative that misses very
key aspects that need to be examined if
you really don't like rioting and you
want to prevent it from happening again
does that matter or will the American
people just remain ignorant to those
facts I think the American people sh on
the end want to hear from this president
in terms of okay if we reelect you again
what will you do to advance the country
forward and solve all of these problems
you created if he wants to talk about an
event a horrific event three years ago
then roll the dice and take your chances
but but in the end those January 6
committee hearings that was made for
MSNBC and CNN audiences and most of the
country tuned out because they have
their own problems to think about and
not something that happened three years
ago where the bias of omission to your
point was on full display all right exit
question for all three of you Tommy will
start with you because you're on record
you don't think Biden's going to be on
the ticket okay if he's not going to be
on the ticket who will be on the ticket
and do you think who do you think win it
on the Republican side we'll know a week
from tonight we'll know something we'll
know about
Iowa I think it's going to be very
interesting but on the Democrat side I'm
still sticking with Gavin Newsome you
dealt in quite a blow with that debate
about a month ago but I still think it's
going to be Gavin Newsome so I think
it's going to be a Nome Trump election
and hang on to your hats and hang on to
your hair gel my friends
kellyan Joe Biden and kamla Harris on
that ticket if I were a Democrat I would
have gotten rid of them a long time ago
rolled the dice and said we're going to
lose in 2024 but we'll save the party
we'll get back to uh being the party of
Youth energy and forward-looking they
can't do it now they think that Biden
beat Trump before he can beat him again
and now they're stuck with him all right
exit question Joe
kcha it's Joe Biden versus Donald Trump
that is the rematch it's the rematch
that not a lot of people are exactly
hungering for but that's what we are
going to have in 2024 I don't see any
curveballs coming at this point I say
too early to decide about on the
Democratic side I don't I this guy's one
one fall away from not being on that
ticket I'll tell you that I'd be very
careful but watch watch every step Joe
you fall in your face you break your
nose not going to be good for you all
right thank you all Tommy kellyanne Joe
kcha happy New Year hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else